so yesterday i introduced you guys to
the new supervillain revtre cg
going through some of her videos
and i found another one that i think
would be interesting to you guys
uh let's see all right here we go
get this ready
new super
dr villain says adults are just obsolete
children
and i believe him
i had a whole bunch to say just a minute
ago and it left my head
this is the problem with not recording
me all the time
and not being in the proper business oh
i know what i could do i'm worrying
about product
placement or if my artwork is my
original
[Music]
parents are just obsolete
adults are just absolute children
my take on that is we're erasing the
fact that we're animals
[Music]
we might be alien beings in these bodies
but our bodies are instinctually
animals and when we deny what we are and
we deny creation
and we decided to be civil and not be
animalistic
is when we die those impulses
and this goes far deep like into
[Music]
jeffrey dahmer consume their victims
because i feel this need to be connected
to something on this earth
sick and twisted as it is i have a
fascination with serial killers and
psychology the is stupid too
because of the way psyche psychiatry and
psychology's practice in the united
states and the european civilized
countries it's about control rather than
accepting your difference
it's about blending thank you miss
peppermint
and laverne cox
dr seuss also says why why
fit in when you can stand out when
you're meant to stand out
people always hated me and put me down
and try to shut me up and
i just have a light that they've put out
and unlike what i've been raised my
whole life to believe i'm not
responsible for their light
it is true the sun is the brightest star
right now in
in our solar system because every star
has a own
duh but the sunshine's [ __ ] bright
and the only time it casts a shadow is
when somebody gets in its way it's not
throwing shade it's casting shadow
not anything to be afraid of you just
crush that obstacle
i'm not responsible for your soul
i'm only responsible for mine
and i'm responsible to pray for those
that i'm told to pray for like when i
was told to pray for ted bundy
on the night of his execution and my
church wouldn't even wake up the prayer
line to do it because
they said it was a waste of their
efforts nobody was going to pray for
that
monster
how is that christ like people of kelso
first assembly of god on academy street
in kelso washington
how is that christ like
no i'm not afraid to mention names
anymore i've decided i'm not afraid of
anything on this earth anymore
man planet animal
the only thing that i'm afraid of is the
loss
of the handful of people that i choose
to surround myself with
the rest of it bucket
if it wasn't for that handful of things
that tie me to this earth
omnicide is my favorite
the sun shines [ __ ] bright
and it doesn't cast shadows
only those that get in its way cast
shadows parents
school government churches
the sun doesn't give a [ __ ] who it burns
what the [ __ ] dude
i don't wish for you to find peace love
and joy
i don't give a [ __ ]
it's in you and if you're too ignorant
to find it
i don't want to talk to you
but if you want to hold hands through
the journey of finding your own joy
join me take a stand for love and peace
and nonpartisan is
anything that makes people quarrel
against each other
acceptance love peace be at one with
nature
go out and kill something you're gonna
eat
raise a chicken
and then kill it to eat it and then tell
me that you're
connected
i killed a grouse
i skinned it
and i gutted it and i hung it upside
down
and i held it in my hand as i felt the
rest of the blood rushing out of it
oh my god oh my god
i've done that with several other
animals
but that's the one that connected me
blessed be i've found peace
you can too there's many teachers out
there
don't worship them learn
from them peace love and joy
it's in you
dude
this is a serial killer in the making
a super villain whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call it
that is insanity
and it's weird because there's some
videos that she makes where she's kind
of normal
but then there's some videos that she
makes where she's a [ __ ] crazy person
it's i i can't i can't figure her out
i am so grateful that i have kept video
record
and written documentation of almost
everything to do
with the behavior of the neighbors
i'm sorry that i've had to go through so
much with the landlord
pills right it seems like pills at
records again
but i'm so glad i have because with them
um
doing this uh restraining order thing
and me applying for special
accommodations it shows
how long i have been dealing with this
stuff from park lane and
here you want to subscribe to her
through the courthouse
because i'll give you the link my own
anxieties and fears that i've just been
keeping record of everything
so i'm gonna have to thank them excuse
me
from when i was extremely obese
it was a ball like a fat cyst
using this side and then the kundalini
yoga
because i had to learn to coordinate
both sides together again you see what i
mean like some of it's i'm not saying
she's normal but
it's not psychotic some of her videos
are psychotic
and some of them are me though as i've
always had them i never had to pray for
them i've always felt i've always been
told i feel
too much i laugh too hard i sing too
loud
imagine if i haven't tried to curb
myself exactly how out of control i
would be in histrionic and need to be in
an asylum
of me is grateful it was whipped out of
me but part of me is horrible at it
because i always had to raise my kids do
as i say not as i do
because i was trained and ingrained and
it was beaten into me and it's hard for
me to unlearn it
not an excuse to keep doing it but still
a reason
so i rambled off on this rant because
i'm having ptsd
going in and out of reliving all of the
stuff with the neighbors and the
violence with their dog coming into my
apartment and snapping at my daughter's
dog
and the confrontations from this woman
who
shoulder bumps me in the hallway and
when i called the police and say she
threatened to kick my ass they tell me
no crime has been committed and to take
it up with my landlords
i have a mental illness so taking it up
with people is hard
and then mental illness is exacerbated
by being poisoned see i used to be a
very strong independent woman asked
people that knew me
before 2015.
ask almost anybody that actually knew me
i was strong and independent whether
they liked me or not i was still strong
and independent and very self-assured
i knew who i was i didn't know what i
wanted i didn't know how to be a good
parent i was always looking to better
myself
but i was very sure of who i was my
self-esteem has always been high because
i know i'm worthwhile the rest of the
world just doesn't see me and that's
frustrating
my daughter my derral emily is teaching
me to voice who i
am without fear well that kind of scares
me because voicing who i am without fear
there's risks and fall out
tact is never something i've learned but
i have learned how to shut up
smile and look pretty i don't like that
side of me
so i don't know why i needed a rant but
i had to vent
somewhere and i guess this was a good
place and i couldn't sit down in
studio because when i sat in the studio
all i kept doing was thinking about this
restraining order [ __ ]
because i gotta get everything in
chronological order and you know
before 2015 asked my professors
i was a research hound
i would research stuff to the point
that my ocd would give me that i would
throw away
an entire quarter's worth of work
and redo it in a week because i wasn't
satisfied with
any of it and i even changed the entire
thesis and i'd still
managed to get a 4.0 or better
now i can barely remember
things and i get my dates flip-flopped
and when i want to say clark county
because i lived in college county for so
long i keep saying college county
you want to know something never once
never once in my history of living in
san luis obispo county
as a teenager did i ever once call that
callouts county
never never got them flipped and
confused
okay lived in santa barbara county when
my kids were small and we were homeless
never got it confused
man it's it's creepy you do all this
joking and stuff aside i'm afraid people
like this are gonna snap dude
i mean that like like that's that
that is like [ __ ] man
um
i i think that's it i've been ending
these like really creepy these shows are
really creepy lately huh with this
i'm again i am super intrigued
by all this stuff